regret non un prêt sans enfant sans
jeunesse sans nouvelle génération il n'y
a rien de ses fils pour que l'on
reconnaisse le monde rural il faut avant
que les naissances web retour chez nous
et tout autour de l'arc en ciel et comme
paris dans les enfants nés
[Applaudissements]
français font de nouveau des familles
dans les cas pour cela je comprenais une
grande politique de natalité et s'écrase
en nous privilégions roues et pas les
départements où il ya plus de 3 enfants
par femme par les grands lieux et
nécropole
j'ai donc décidé de vous présenter la
mesure faisait la plus forte jamais
composé de français qui va l'accompagner
une mesure pour les familles pour nos
enfants une mesure pour la jeunesse une
mesure pour la qualité une mesure pour
l'avenir une mesure pour le retour de la
france pour l'avenir de la france pour
la survie
en mettant fin à l' émirat s'ils en
mettent un frein à la sas canada s'est
sauvé en mesure de financer le grand
plan de développement de la nike aidant
nouvelle pour tous les citoyens de la
france human